when there's one exercise that's being
used by pretty much
every military every athletic coach then
you should really
pay it some attention but you don't tend
to see that much attention given to the
burpee at least
not here on youtube and i think the
reason for this is that it falls into a
kind of
no man's land so you have your
calisthenics aficionados
who like to use controlled movements
like to hold these cool poses like
planche and handstand push-ups
and they don't have much use for burpees
people who want explosiveness and more
likely to use plyometrics then in a more
shocking manner for
lower rep ranges and people who want to
build strength are going to want to add
more resistance and so you don't tend to
see burpees
being promoted all that much this is a
shame because burpees are actually
extremely valuable exercises extremely
versatile
with a ton of amazing benefits and so
that's what i'm going to talk about
right now so obviously the main reason
to do burpees is because they're a
fantastic form
of conditioning when you do a burpee
your body is in movement
the entire time there's no point where
you're stationary between reps you don't
lock out at the top of the movement and
it utilizes your entire body not just a
single limb
this of course jumps the heart rate up
really high really quickly
as your body has to try and get blood to
all of the different working muscles
and so in this way it can be used in a
similar manner to a kettlebell swing it
can be used as part of a circuit or in
one long continuous series of
repetitions and this is a great way to
get the heart rate up very quickly in a
small amount of space without having to
go
running or something similar and because
you're using both the upper and the
lower body the heart has to work and
produce this
shunting effect to move the blood from
the lower body to the upper body and
then back again
and because there is some resistance
this is also a form of resistance cardio
which is
even better at getting you to work even
harder because you're not just moving
the body you're moving it against a
little bit of resistance
in this case your own body weight and
this is also a great way to burn extra
calories particularly at the end of a
workout as a finisher
but without risking cannibalizing your
muscle because you're still using it
this can protect it
to a certain degree so yeah bruce lee
actually used something called
peripheral heart action
training and what this basically meant
was that he was alternating the use of
different body parts within a circuit
so instead of using a bodybuilder
approach and doing all of his arm
exercises together then all of his leg
exercises together
he'd instead go from an arm exercise to
a shoulder exercise to a leg exercise
and by doing this he was able to ensure
that the blood was constantly
circulating around the body
thereby providing a form of conditioning
at the same time as his strength
training
and so the great thing about burpees of
course is that you're getting the same
shunting effect within a single exercise
as you alternate between upper body
lower body
upper body lower body and that's
extremely valuable in other words you're
not just training your ability to lift
something
really heavy once you're training your
ability to exert strength
over and over and over again without
fatiguing which is exactly what you have
to do
in real life combat situations as well
as in sports
often strength endurance is more
important than max strength because
when do you ever get the chance to use
your maximum strength and this of course
is also
why the military and athletic coaches
like the burpees so much
because it also builds strength
endurance i got rained on
it happens we're okay so to perform a
burpee
most people know how to do this but
there are some little checks we can use
to make sure we're doing it properly
basically what you're going to do is to
drop down into a squatting position from
standing up
then you're going to sprawl that means
kick your legs out behind you into a
push-up position you'd be starting the
top of the push-up and then lowering
yourself down to perform a single rep
as you push yourself back up jump back
up to the hands and then jump straight
up
in the air and then land softly by
absorbing that impact with your knees
this should look like one nice seamless
movement so as you drop down
you're already moving into the lower
position of the push-up and then as you
jump back up
you can launch yourself straight back
into the air using some of the momentum
from the top of the push-up
of course you want to make sure that
you're not sagging your waist you want
to maintain a nice strong core at the
same time this is one of the benefits of
the exercise it's also a core exercise
at the same time when you jump your legs
up to your hands you want to be in a
kind of squat position
and then jump up from there you want to
be folding your body over down in half
you hear some people quibble as to
whether or not your feet should land on
the inside or the outside
of your arms that really doesn't matter
so much so that of course is one of the
other advantages of the burpee
it's pretty much a full body movement
because you're training the legs with
that squat
the upper body the chest the shoulders
the triceps with the push-up
and then at the same time you're
training the core by holding yourself
nice and rigid
and then by straightening yourself back
up there's even a slight
hip hinge movement here a slight triple
extension from the ankle's hips
and knees so you're practicing your
ability to jump up high
so in theory this is the perfect
exercise that's going to hit pretty much
everything it's burning fat it's
improving your work capacity and your
cardio your strength endurance
at the same time it's training nearly
every muscle in your body
of course there are some limitations
though firstly
it's not really every muscle in your
body there's a very slight
pulling element some people say they
feel it in their laps because you're
also
pulling your body towards the hands when
you jump forwards
so it is one of the closest things you
can get to a pulling exercise
using body weight but it's really not
much it's not going to replace it pull
up or lat pull down
at the same time there's no rotation you
guys know that i love rotation and
there's no
single leg strength so yeah there's no
such thing as one exercise that will
train
everything but the truly great thing
about the burpee is the sheer number of
variations because there's so many
variables to play with
you can create all kinds of different
variations to target different muscles
and to offer different benefits so for
instance if you want
to add a rotational aspect to this
movement then you can combine it with
a kick through that's what it's called
in animal fly i believe it's also
sometimes called a
kick sit or a sit through basically it's
going to look like this
um
now you have rotation you've also got
man makers where you perform the
movement like a devil press holding
dumbbells what you're going to do is
support your weight at the top of the
push-up movement on just one hand
row on the other side using
anti-rotational
stability in the core to prevent
yourself twisting then do the other side
push up jump up clean press and back
down that trains
loads of stuff it doesn't take a rocket
science to work out how to get single
leg strength in there
you're just going to do your burpee on a
single leg like so
by the same token for more of that sweet
anti-rotation
you can perform the whole movement on a
single arm instead
also if you want more of a pulling
movement you can also perform this
underneath the pull-up bar jump up grab
the pull-up bar perform a pull-up
drop down burpee you get the idea want
to make the movement
more explosive more about that jump
height simple
you just jump higher
and of course there's easier variations
you'd have to do the push-up you don't
have to jump your legs out you can
move them out more slowly ultimately
this just involves getting down into
that position
and then getting back up and if that's
all you can do then that's a fantastic
starting point that will build you up to
much more impressive movements and give
you that kind of resilience and core
strength
in the process want more of a chest
hypertrophy focus want to build
bigger pecs and triceps then just
perform more push-ups in between
each of the jumps you can do this with a
navy seal burpee where you bring your
knee up as well on the second two
push-ups for a total of three push-ups
per rep obviously a big limitation of
this if you're looking to build strength
is the amount of resistance which isn't
that much and also the range of motion
which is pretty short
the time under tension is pretty short
and there's big gaps in between so if
your main
interest is bodybuilding or building
pure strength then the burpee
probably isn't going to cut it for you
however there are some ways of course to
add weight
you can just wear a weight vest for
instance you can slow down the movement
if you want to focus more on strength
alternatively you could even hold a pair
of dumbbells and do something like a
devil press and the other thing to
consider
is that strength isn't all about adding
resistance and creating micro tears
creating muscle damage it's also about
learning motor patterns and reinforcing
those
pathways so essentially by doing so many
push-ups and so many air squats and
jumps
you're able to grease the groove and
become better at those movements so you
become stronger
in that sense you just become more
efficient and especially at bracing your
core
especially when fatigued just does
translate to better performance
that has to do with power and strength
another great thing
about the burpee and movements like it
is that this is a hybrid exercise
that means you're actually combining two
or more exercises into a single
repetition so in this case you're
combining a push-up
and a squat and a jump all together and
there you have your hybrid
the great thing about this is that it
trains you to not only perform those
movements well
but also trains you to perform the
transition between those movements to
handle things like
momentum and the differing levels of
fatigue you have throughout the exercise
basically instead of performing one
exercise in a static location
over and over again which isn't how real
life works
you're moving dynamically from one
position to another one
quickly and reacting to various
different factors
that's how we move in the real world
that's how you move in sports in combat
so of course it provides a more
resilient strength a more robust
strength
and this translates to better more
functional performance and of course if
you can't choose between these different
awesome variations then you also have
the opportunity to just
mix and match you can do this by just
improvising and
going with the flow jumping from a kick
through to a single leg
burpee to a high up jump to a single arm
burpee whatever else
or you can follow a set routine that you
know is going to hit every single body
part every single movement pattern
and again this isn't going to provide
you with lots of hypertrophy lots of
muscle damage
max strength but in terms of building
resilience learning motor patterns and
strengthening your core and burning fat
at the same time there are a few things
better than a
insane routine like this and so that's
why
i think everyone should be doing the
burpee so i hope you found this
somewhat useful and interesting guys if
you did then please leave a like and
share around
that helps me out immensely i really
appreciate it
do you use burpees comment down below
and let me know why not if you don't and
what your favorite variation is if you
do there's many more there's
two pump and three pump burpees
bodybuilders all sorts of different
things i'd love to hear what your
favorites are maybe there's
some that you invented if you like this
kind of training then be sure to check
out my ebook and training program
super functional training it focuses on
this kind of thing building
a more performant body not just muscle
not just strength not just
cardio but all round better performance
even cognitive performance because
you know that's what i think fitness is
training all of your capacities
to be as good as they can be there's a
discount on right now whilst everyone's
dealing with the pandemic
man i've been saying that for a long
time or if you'd just like to learn more
about functional training and how it
applies to you and
everybody else then you can also check
out my print book functional training
and beyond it's available on amazon on
audible
and i'll leave a link to that in
description down below as well
subscribe if you want to see more like
this hit the bell notification button if
you want to be notified each time we
upload a video
thank you so much for watching this one
and i'll see you next time
thanks a ton and bye for now